a new partnership between beijing and
budapest has angered hungarian taxpayers
who will have to carry the nearly 1
billion euro financial burden
china is building a european campus of
its
shanghai-based fudan university not only
are hungarians to pick up the tab but no
local contractors will get to work on
the project
most hungarians oppose the plan and
anger is growing against prime minister
victor orban thousands have taken to the
streets of the capital to protest their
government's cooperation
with an authoritarian regime
the area behind this fence in budapest
was supposed to become
the home to more than ten thousand
students
the plan to build affordable dorms
especially for people from hungary's
rural areas the ground has been broken
for various projects including a new
athletic stadium
but the government is also allowing
china to build the very first european
campus
of the shanghai-based food and
university on the site
according to government documents
obtained by the hungarian investigative
media outlet
direct 36 the chinese campus will be
financed by a 1.3
billion euro loan paid for by hungarian
taxpayers
the journalist behind the report sees
other worrying implications for the
projects
sauboche pony says hungary's
intensifying ties with china
create a friendly environment for
chinese intelligence
there's an increasing number of chinese
students flowing in
to the country and china is known for
using
its citizens forcing them to feed
information
due to chinese intelligence so the
larger the chinese footprint is
in hungary the larger the risk of
espionage
during various visits with his chinese
counterparts over the past decade
prime minister viktor orban has been
openly pursuing
an eastern opening strategy in the hopes
of attracting
chinese investment at the beginning of
the covet pandemic
orban personally inspected tons of
protective equipment
that had arrived at the budapest airport
from china
hungary is also the only country in the
eu
pre-inoculated citizens with the chinese
coveted vaccine
and it recently vetoed an eu joint
statement
expressing concern over china's
tightening control over
hong kong so who really benefits from
this relationship hungary i think
has vetoed the the most
in favor of china so china is the number
one beneficiary of
hungary's disruptive power inside the eu
but we don't actually see
chinese foreign direct investment
flowing and pouring in
to the country the campus for example
will be built
using chinese labor and building
material shipped in
from china and not everyone in hungary
is a fan of the eastern opening strategy
budapest's mayor gargay karachong
is a key opponent of orban he has been
showing his opposition to what he calls
chinese influence buying in his own
special way
four streets near the planned chinese
construction site have recently been
renamed students at the new campus may
have to take
dalai lama road or free hong kong road
to get to class well for more on this
let's go straight to our correspondent
funifachar
in in budapest hi funny now protesters
against this project have been out
voicing their anger we can hear them
there behind you
and roughly two-thirds of hungarians
oppose it now
what are their main concerns
[Applause]
the main concern is the financial burden
it's estimated that this entire project
is going to cost about 1.3 billion euros
paid by the hungarian taxpayer a chinese
loan
right now currently actually the mayor
of budapest is speaking
mr karacho actually wants to run against
prime minister obama in national actions
next year and he says
there's so many different things that
could be done with this money
in fact people have gathered here some
who are actually also supporting
the fitness party the governing party
are saying they're disappointed because
actually this project or the money
that's needed for affordable housing
it's now going to be used
for this chinese project but people are
also making clear
they're not against chinese people in
hungary but they are questioning the
financial scope
of this entire project that is putting a
burden on the hungarian taxpayer and
let's not forget
hungary is among one of the most corrupt
countries in the european union
so it is concerned that through this
project the government and people that
are close to the
upper elite of hungary is just simply
going to use this as
an opportunity to stash away money
right so the hungarian government has
come out in defense of the plant now
chinese university campus but
who really benefits from this
relationship with china
the hungarian government says that
hungarians are also going to benefit
from this project because
actually fudan university is one of the
most prestigious universities one of the
best universities of china
so it can only increase education
competition here in hungary
by setting up the very first european
campus of food and university here in
hungary so they say hungary is actually
and hungarians
is going to hungarians are going to
benefit from it but if you zoom in on
the project
as i say it's reportedly going to be
financed by the hungarian taxpayer
and it's going to be built by a chinese
people coming
from china and buy chinese material so
there you clearly ask yourself then
who is going to benefit this project is
it really hungary or is it rather
china and chinese intelligent that
through the help of
hungary is going to set a foot into
europe
in budapest thank you
you